alors c'est pas toujours été facile avec
dutronc et pourtant vous aviez eu les
les plus grandes stars à vos pieds moi
je sais qu'on m'attend mais attendez
brian jones mick jagger bob dylan c'est
vrai quand même
françoise mothes dylan c'est vrai mais
il paraît qu est ce qui est vrai gill
and the gila dont 64 ans dont on est on
est né en 64 que je sais pas c'est le
mérite de dire ce qui s'est passé bob
dylan en 64 tombe en arrêt devant une
photo de françoise hardy en couverture
de bugs fait par william klein il en
fait personne ne connaissait bob dylan à
l'époque il venait voir hugues aufray
hugues aufray voulait adapter les
chansons de bob dylan en france donc
fait l'autre venait le voir et deux ans
plus tard il revient il est dans sa loge
à l'olympia il refuse de monter sur
scène tant qu'il n'a pas vu grand chose
arrive c'est vrai ça ouais ouais gt gt
je les folles de boldin de bob dylan
j'adorais ses chansons mon rêve c'était
de loi sur scène il arrive à paris pour
chanter à ce moment là j'étais sur un
tournage avec yves montand on était à
monaco et je suppliais john
frankenheimer de me laisser monter à
paris pour le concert de bob dylan et
comme il devait avoir des penchants un
peu sadiques john frankenheimer il m'a
dit le dernier jour ce moment-là veuille
me dit bon tu peux aller tu peux aller à
paris et puis la grosse déception parce
que bob dylan n'était pas au meilleur de
sa forme et vraiment c'est le moins
qu'on puisse dire
et il a déçu les attentes du public car
c'était pas c'était pas très bon la
manière dont il a chanté dont il a joué
de la guitare et c est donc à l'entracte
il ne revenait pas puisqu'il faisait les
deux parties est quelqu'un est venu me
demander d'aller dans sa loge
parce que sinon il ne remontait pas sûr
voilà je me souviens absolument pas de
ce qui a pu se passer dans sa loge moi
j'étais terrifiée je vis une espèce de
vampires jaune avec avec des ongles trop
lent marais c'était hugo ferait alors le
bon choix je ne vous raconte pas c'est
qu'ensuite vous allez tous avec zoom
johnny hallyday hugo fait vous au george
et 5
bob dylan is not complètement le johnny
hallyday zouzou et hugues aufray il vous
prend dans sa dans sa suite voyage il me
prostitue à 106 royal et il vous fait
écouter just like a woman show comme toi
la grande chanson oui vous l'avez vous
l'avez revu après non non non mais c'est
passionnant et je suis et je sais j'ai
su que récemment quand il était à paris
peut-être pas la dernière fois mais
l'avant dernière fois alors qu'en 2002
il avait vieilli maintenant je m'occupe
aussi la procédure
en fin de manche je sais qu'il a demandé
de mes nouvelles je préfère qu'il reste
avec le fantasme de la photo de mes 20
ans plutôt que me voir que voir la ruine
que je suis devenu la saisir comme ça
arrêtez vous un bon